in the world ukraine russia has targeted
kiev for the first time in more than a
month missiles rained down on ukraine's
capital yesterday while both sides kept
on fighting for control of a key city in
eastern ukraine chris lipsey is
following the attacks in both regions
a building burst into flames russia
claims it struck tanks inside donated
from ukrainian allies but leonid a local
resident says there's nothing in there
but rail cars
it's a repair shop not a military
factory he says vladimir putin is
determined to show he can still strike
whenever and wherever he wants by air
far from the battlefields of eastern
ukraine which have crept into elena
holothka's front yard
peacefully she says now we have nothing
left
the war has never been bloodier ukraine
says it's losing between 60 and 100
troops per day roughly twice the number
of american soldiers lost daily at the
height of the vietnam war russia now
occupies 20 percent of ukrainian
territory says ukrainian president
vladimir zelinsky who visited the
embattled donbass region far from the
capital of kiev
in this deadly struggle of tug of war
ukraine has recaptured territory in
severo donetsk and is intent on pushing
russian troops back to their border with
the help of advanced long-range missile
systems on route from the united states
once they get here vladimir putin is now
vowing russia will strike new targets in
retaliation but nothing has stopped him
from pounding this country for more than
100 days even turning hunger into a
weapon russia has blockaded ukraine's
ports some 20 million tons of grain
destined for the developing world now
risk rotting on the docks for cbs
morning's chris livesay odessa ukraine